5 gramm reines herz wenn man das wird
johnson brothers war am 15 das war ca
250 tradition gefahren und das ist
verdammt unkompliziert zu tun das war
verdammt da schon dreimal haben oder wie
macht man ein altes heilmittel das
zwischenzeitlich erging verruf geraten
ist wieder salonfähig
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
manfred hauser ist der einzige
apothekerin der schweiz der berechtigt
ist hanf anzubauen dessen blüten zu
touren und ölen zu verarbeiten und diese
zu verkaufen er und sein team versorgen
600 patienten regelmäßig mit
cannabisprodukten etwa zwei drittel
dieser menschen behandeln damit
schmerzen in zusammenhang mit ms rheuma
oder tumoren ja mixa datum sehr schön
den täglich also wird die fahrzeuge
erwartet dass sie da waren martina warum
sie das ist jetzt gar nicht für das dank
medialer umbau ist yaman
hochsicherheitstrakt mit speziellen
verlassen mit bewegungsmelder also dass
man vorsichtig sein muss machen die
vorherige darf ja und der manforter so
frenzel darf also rossi hat bzw
das fossil war hier liegt geht welches
packen und los geht der mann vorsieht
dass du rennst nick sie ja nachdem ich
denke dass das ausmaß an
[Musik]
am berner inselspital findet ein
kongress zum thema cannabinoide in der
medizin neue trends statt
die schweizer arbeitsgruppe für
cannabinoide in der medizin hat
hochkarätige referenten aus der ganzen
welt eingeladen um einem interessierten
fachpublikum die neuesten stand der
forschung vorzustellen
fankhauser erinnert sich noch gut an
eine zeit auch solche veranstaltungen im
kleinen kreis statt fanden damals war er
als doktor der pharmakologie ein exot
unter lauter kiffen denen es vor allem
darum ging das rauchen von cannabis zu
legalisieren
[Musik]
gut hier ist natürlich schon auf die
neue stärke ist das forschungsforum
gleich etwas passiert
die meisten herrschaftliches fragen im
labor sehr wichtig oder
grundlagenforschung und ich komme aus
der praxis viele beitrag geleistet da
ist es vielleicht dass man cannabis
wieder zu der patientin
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
was machen sie da wieder mal auf ihn
einfach einklang mit ziehen und das blut
das durch kurt frau mehr darunter
applications li dolph dort aber fand er
auch wirklich entlastet und der gott
david besser aber so wie jeder dass du
gut
[Musik]
die wöchentliche physiotherapie gehört
zusätzlich wengers höhepunkten
sie war mit ihrem mann in den ferien als
sie plötzlich feststellte dass etwas
nicht stimmte zurück in der schweiz
erhielt sie die diagnose multiple
sklerose da war sie mit der 30 heute ist
sie mitte 50 und seit fünf jahren im
rollstuhl
[Musik]
cannabis tropfen machen mit der süchtig
nach high und haben kaum nebenwirkungen
sie könnten ihre krankheit zwar nicht
heilen aber ein bisschen erträglicher
machen findet 6 il wenger
[Musik]
oder ganz oberschenkel ist eine kommune
die maschine dann muss ich warten bis
das ist nicht immer besser aber es ist
besser im ganzen gesehen
ms verläuft unvorhersehbar
prognosen sind kaum möglich was noch auf
sie zukommt kann die raus und man zu
genau sagen aber ich glaube ja einfach
sie für krankheiten politisch
[Musik]
richtig bekannt geworden ist cannabis in
den 60er jahren die droge und seine
konsumenten haben ein entsprechendes
image bekommen
leute die gern als gammler verwahrloste
aber auch vernachlässigte als nichtstuer
aus leidenschaft und als zurückgesetzte
als irgendwie in opposition zur
gesellschaft stehende beschrieben werden
inzwischen ist klar dass cannabis nicht
nur berauschend sondern auch heilen kann
die bilder von damals wirken allerdings
bis heute nach
[Musik]
in trub im emmental wuchs in den 60er
jahren ein rausch der in seinem leben
ganze zwei joints rauchen sollte und
auch zu dem interesse für cannabis auch
sonst wenig gemein hat mit einem hippie
starker würde ich sage ich habe mich
durchsetzen muss sie und wenn die mauer
bis im hopfengarten stangen überzeugt
dass ich richtig oder roter da kann ich
daran ist doch wie aber als auch wenn
ein spürhund warten würde mal sagen weh
tun musste sich nicht
naja bin ich hier ist fankhauser
ausbauen sohn zur welt gekommen sein
vater starb früh die mutter zog ihre
sieben söhne alleine groß es war eine
kindheit geprägt von armut und
entbehrungen dann schaffen wir stehen ja
sagt berührte und der seit natürlich
berger verwaister und das wasser und
sorgte im exil eine mini geht der große
kater effekte norden trends kroschinsky
und der menschliche traum kämpfen oder
inwiefern hat sie ihre herkunft prägt
die autos noch schwierig deswegen nicht
sehr neugierig sie gar nicht zwar
verschlechterte sich aber gerne tue sehr
offen - kritiker verschiedene sachen
gemacht verkehrs kv arrangiert nach
pharmazie studiert und das ist es ist
neugierig irgendwie sz zitiert
dann dabur von krieg oder viel geld
verdienen das ist das ist also ein
masterplan hany azer hat das zu einer
eigenen apotheke in langnau im emmental
gebracht
den grundstein zum erfolg legte er mit
einer doktorarbeit zum thema haschisch
aus medikament dabei erkannte er das
gewaltige therapeutische potential der
pflanze bald machte er sich einen namen
als cannabis experte den ärzte und
patienten um rat fragte das benehmen
wirklich unmittelbar kontaktiert worden
durch mitpatienten holiday visums
probierte verboten ist unter großer
nutzer und das ist eine motivation nach
ich sie ja dann ist alles danach aussah
aber schlussendlich der patienten
möglichkeit das ja legal zu dem
medikament römer es war der amerikaner
harry zenzinger der vor gut 50 jahren
ein cannabis verbot durchsetzte während
der prohibition kämpfte ensslin
us-federal bureau of narcotics vor allem
gegen alkohol
nach dem ende der prohibition suchte
seine behörde eine neue aufgabe und fand
den krieg gegen cannabis
der cannabis-konsum ache verrückt
behauptete ensslin
eigens produzierte propaganda filmchen
sollten zeigen wohin das führt etwa zu
kaltblütigem mord und historischen
kirche
[Musik]
als mitglied der drogen kommission der
vereinten nationen setzte inzlingen in
den 60er jahren schließlich ein
weltweites verbot des cannabis anbaus
durch
[Musik]
und dann kam der bauernschlaue
fankhauser und fand während seiner
doktorarbeit heraus dass thc nicht nur
aus holz sondern auch aus zitronen
schauen gewonnen werden konnte also baut
er das bundesamt für gesundheit um die
erlaubnis mit thc forschen zu können
das sei verboten meinte das baby in
einem langen papierkrieg konnte er
jedoch beweisen dass sein trc nichts mit
cannabis zu tun hatte also es ist auch
die juristische spitzfindigkeit geht es
mal wieder mit bruder gefällig und dass
man dass das ist möglich und jan haase
ist die bewegung gar zu beginn einfach
effizienter machen und das habe eine
relativ rasche craxi der 16 patienten
das wetter brauchen unsere sportliche
märz das hätte verschrieben und 2030
aufgenommen bis im jahr 2011 was nach
dem gesetz das antritt das natürliche
cannabis präparat wieder verbraucher und
vor der halle verwandelt
das brg verfolgt bankhauses wirken
seither mit großem interesse
markus sie anleitet hier die sektion
drogen dass cannabis ein gewaltiges
medizinisches potenzial hat ist heute
unbestritten
umso erstaunlicher ist dass pharmafirmen
dazu kam forschen
es könnte sie das so meint eine
patentrechtlich bedanke bestand wir
leben cannabis als pflanze haben wir
nicht so einfach patentieren how
wirkstoffen wer patentier aber nicht
unbedingt die pflanze aber anders jetzt
durch ruß aus oder das pharmaindustrie
schlicht einfach konkurrenz fürchtet für
ein medikament zu wischen schmerzmittel
umso mehr oder als cannabis oder relativ
einfach arzt panisch und sehr billig ist
und wirklich zur medikamentenentwicklung
thürig
[Musik]
elsbeth witschi ist seit drei jahren
cannabis konsumenten die mit 90 green
fühlt sich wieder so fit dass sie sich
sogar einen hometrainer rang geschafft
hat
und macht dann aber doch nichts umzug
noch studieren doch nicht
sie konnte kaum mehr gehen so schlimm
war die arthrose heute sei sie ein neuer
mensch sagt sie und frau sei ein held
[Musik]
ihr schlafzimmer sei heute wieder ein
ort der freude
[Musik]
wie haben sie den tag schlafe bevor sie
die cannabis tropfen hand das ist dass
du so gut
patienten wie es mit wissen über ihren
hausarzt eine spezial bewilligung des
bhg beantragen um die cannabis tropfen
zu kommen
diese bewilligung bekommt nur wer
nachweisen kann dass alle herkömmlichen
therapie versuche gescheitert sind dass
er also austherapiert ist was geht und
was geht der dank geht an angel nieto
man auch hier appetitlosigkeit ist
verschwunden sie ist wieder mit genuss
es haben sich allerdings merkwürdige
gelüste eingestellt ich denke doch noch
nicht weg dazu machen das weiß ich
[Musik]
was dann quasi frei wie kiwis die szene
uni dir tropfen
während sie darauf trainiert das ist
aber nicht richtig sie aber ich nehme es
natürlich schön cannabis hilft bei
typischen autos beschwerden wie
schmerzen appetit und schlaflosigkeit
wäre da nicht anzunehmen dass vielen
senioren geholfen werden könnte wenn sie
leichter zu cannabis kämen
das ist so dann brauche ich aber dazu
aufruft eben eigentlich auch wieder
entwicklungen oft wissenschaften name
sondern auch politische motive
ausgesetzt und ist auch sehr
rahmenbedingungen setze für die isar 2
cannabishaltige medikamente patienten
muss therapiert sie es gar nur bei
schweren erkrankungen und solange das
der fall ist oder und ausländer werden
wiederum über politisch war
ich spiele sehr gering
im bundes bayern sperrt sich vor allem
die rechte gegen weitere
liberalisierungen denn wenn die
medizinische nutzung erleichtert würde
könnte auch die legalisierung des
gipfels näher rücken so die logik
derweil nehmen die ausnahmebewilligungen
des berges stetig zu
seine apotheke betreibt mit seiner frau
einer drogistin
hier ist es in den vergangenen jahren
immer enger geworden weil das cannabis
geschäft boomt mussten die vom chaos
immer mehr mitarbeiter einstellen
mitunter schwieriger spagat der frauen
auftrete machen also aber musste nicht
wie irrtümlich als kranken sieht ja was
passiert immer jahr 252 gesetz nun mit
licht und sauerstoff baut das in seiner
karriere dann habe ich auch wieder spaß
also dem kmu stellen sich auch so
betriebswirtschaftliche fragen
gleichzeitig belastet von pause aber
auch die stetig steigende
arbeitsbelastung europa familie dran
das hat schon bedient man cds büchern
hatte sich zurückziehe oder
forschungsprojekt zu entwickeln
jetzt ist es zeit von freitag 15
diese bietet verwaltungsstrukturen als
wasser auf den ofen ist wichtig
[Musik]
in solothurn trifft sich derweil die
eidgenössische kommission für
suchtfragen
während sich die politik schwer tut die
medizinische nutzung von cannabis
pragmatisch zu liberalisieren stellen
die praktiker fest dass die bürger das
recht zunehmend in die eigenen hände
nehmen immer mehr menschen konsumieren
cannabis um medizinische beschwerden zu
kurieren
ohne eine erlaubnis dafür zu haben das
ist für die schweiz gehen wir davon aus
dass es etwa hunderttausend leute so
machen
einerseits machen sich all diese
menschen strafbar andererseits besorgen
sie sich cannabis dass keinerlei
qualitätskontrollen unterliegt
darum ist die situation auch der große
sicht und treffend gesundheit nicht gut
die ist das heißt es die städte durch
rosa wie sie aufgaben nach marken wie
hummer dafür sorgen dass mancher war
wirklich was medizinische gründe
cannabis konsumiert was machen ohne das
werk eine kriminelle tat kriminalität
abzugleiten
die flaschen ist ein erfolg ausmacht was
im moment möglich ist
immer mehr menschen wollen und erwarten
viel von cannabis apotheker und seinen
tropfen potenzials sicher groß aber die
war nämlich vor übertriebenen
erwartungen jetzt geht aus einem
heutigen zeit ich kann aber ist in aller
munde ist sehr populär ist viel mit
kopfarbeit
das zwischenhoch ist aufgabe müsse sehr
viel patient oder mögliche patienten
typischen also mir sehr viele fragen wo
man schon nach fünf minuten merkt das
ist cannabis würde was nicht der ganze
waren durch sein müsste man gewaltige
dampfer nach der bürger
[Musik]